Bonjour, ravie de vous retrouver pour cet
épisode cette fois-ci dédié à l’archéologie
d’une zone précise, la vallée de l’Indus. Avant
de plonger dans les vestiges de cette civilsation,
je tenais à vous remercier du fond du coeur
pour tous vos commentaires sous la vidéo des
penseurs du XXe, je pense sincèrement refaire
ce type de format qui vous plait tant ! Si je
n’ai pas été très présente pour vous répondre
c’est que j’étais en reportage à l’étranger
pour un projet absolument fou en Arabie
Saoudite. Je vous en reparle très vite,
je vous invite à activer la cloche et
à me suivre sur Instagram pour être
tenu au courant de la sortie de cette vidéo !
Il y a des civilisations qui passent inaperçues.
Pourtant celle dont on va parler aujourd’hui a
dominé un territoire d’un million de kilomètres
carrés pendant sept cents ans, possédait sa propre
écriture, des villes de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d’habitants et commerçait avec tout le
Moyen-Orient. Cette civilisation, c’est Harappa
du nom du premier grand site identifié, mais on
l'appelle aussi la civilisation de l’Indus du nom
du fleuve au bord duquel elle s’est épanouie.
Harappa nous est donc pratiquement inconnue.
Rien à voir avec les dizaines de livres de
vulgarisation qui sortent tous les ans sur
l’Egypte, la Grèce ou même la Mésopotamie.
Et il y a plusieurs raisons à cela. Déjà,
parce que le Pakistan où se trouvent la
majorité des sites, n’est pas un pays
spécialement touristique du fait d’un contexte
géopolitique assez tendu ; ensuite parce que les
sites archéologiques, faits de briques crues
pour la plupart, ne sont pas aussi majestueux
que ceux de l’Egypte pharaonique. Mais Harappa
est inconnue chez nous aussi et surtout parce
qu’il n’y a pratiquement pas de bibliographie
en français. Tout au plus quelques pages dans
les ouvrages généraux sur l’histoire de l’Inde.
On attend peut-être un volume de la collection
Mondes anciens sur le sous-continent indien pour
avoir quelque chose de plus complet et accessible.
Les sources qui ont servi à préparer cet
épisode proviennent donc en grande majorité
de publications en anglais. Ce sont des revues
internationales spécialisées comme le Journal
of Archeological Science, donc pas du tout
vulgarisé, même si certains articles sont
accessibles gratuitement sur internet. Et puis il
faut bien avouer que les articles anglo-saxons ont
la fâcheuse tendance d’être assez creux. C’est pas
du racisme anti-anglais que de dire ça, c’est le
reflet des conditions de la recherche : plutôt que
de publier une synthèse complète qui sert à tout
le monde, on découpe un article pour le publier
dans quatre revues différentes et faire plus
de lignes sur son CV. Résultat, les infos sont
éparpillées et c’est très difficile d’avoir une
bonne vue d’ensemble quand on est pas spécialiste.
Je vous passe aussi les publications de 1000
pages qui compilent 30 ans de fouilles d’un seul
site, je vous le cache pas, on a pas eu le temps…
Moralité, cette vidéo essaie de donner un
aperçu rapide de cette civilisation malgré
toutes ces difficultés. Heureusement pour nous,
il y a un bon livre de synthèse récent en langue
anglaise, c’est celui de Jane McIntosh,
beaucoup utilisé pour ce qui va suivre.
Commençons par aller voir une carte, parce
que je sais pas vous, mais le Pakistan,
c’était pas forcément le pays avec lequel
j’étais le plus familière. L’Indus est un
fleuve qui descend de l’Himalaya au Nord et
qui va se jeter dans l’Océan indien au Sud.
La vallée est encadrée par les montagnes de
l’Hindou Kouch et du Baloutchistan à l’ouest,
et le grand désert de Thar à l’est. C’est donc
un espace assez contraint géographiquement et les
grands sites de peuplement humain sont logiquement
installés au bord du fleuve et du littoral.
Les sites de la vallée de l’Indus sont découverts
dans les années 1820 mais fouillés cent ans plus
tard. Excavées à grands coups de pioches par
des centaines d’ouvriers au début du XXe siècle,
les grandes villes de la vallée de l’Indus ont
bien livré quantité d’objets archéologiques,
mais toute information sur leur disposition
ou leur position dans la stratigraphie est
à jamais perdue. Technique de bourrin. Par
ailleurs, les villes, et en particulier Harappa,
ont servi de carrières de briques à toutes
les époques postérieures, ce qui a grandement
endommagé les constructions et rendu souvent
impossible de dresser des plans d’ensemble.
Partant de là, les fouilles au XXe siècle
ont toutefois mis au jour une civilisation
particulièrement originale. Avec ses plans de
villes orthogonaux, orientés parfaitement sur les
points cardinaux, son omniprésence d’évacuations
d’eau et de salles de bain dans les maisons,
ou encore son extrême standardisation des mesures,
dès le IIIe millénaire avant J.-C., Harappa
a profondément surpris les archéologues. Les
milliards de briques harappéennes qui ont servi
à construire les villes ont toutes des dimensions
de 1 par 2 par 4. Les poids utilisés pour le
commerce sont tous des multiples d’une unité de
base de 0,87 grammes, et toutes les longueurs
sont basées sur une unité de 17 millimètres.
On connaît quelques très grandes agglomérations,
qui s’étendent sur des centaines d’hectares :
Harappa, Mohenjo-Daro, Ganweriwala, Chanhu-Daro,
Rakhigarhi, Dholavira, etc. La culture harappéenne
est présente sur plus de mille sites en tout dont
une centaine ont été fouillés, mais à eux seuls,
les sites de Mohenjo-Daro et Harappa cumulent 87
% du matériel retrouvé. Les datations
font aujourd’hui remonter la fondation
de ces villes vers 2500 avant notre ère.
L’économie de subsistance est basée sur
l’élevage du zébu, avec transhumance une partie
de l’année et l’agriculture céréalière du blé
et de l'orge. Les ressources sauvages complètent
évidemment le régime alimentaire, en particulier
le poisson du fleuve. Les champs sont irrigués
au moyen de retenues d’eau et de canalisations,
alimentés par les pluies et les rivières.
Le climat permet deux récoltes par an, une
agriculture d’hiver (rabi) de type méditerranéen,
avec céréales, lentilles, pois-chiches, raisin,
figues, dattes, pistaches et amandes, et
une culture d’été (kharif) plus tropicale,
qui comprend le coton, le millet, le sorgho,
la canne à sucre, la mangue, les haricots ou
encore le sésame dont on extrait l’huile. Cette
double culture permet de réduire les risques. Les
rendements dans la vallée de l’Indus peuvent
être très bons mais sont assez irréguliers.
La grande uniformité des objets, des techniques et
des constructions constatée dans tous les sites,
l’agriculture irriguée à grande échelle,
tout fait penser à l’existence d’un État
centralisé dans la vallée de l’Indus dans
l’Antiquité. Pourtant, malgré cette unité
apparente, les traces d’une organisation
politique ou religieuse manquent toujours.
On ne connaît pas en effet, dans toute la vallée
de l’Indus, de résidence ou de palais qui aurait
pu jouer le rôle de centre administratif.
On ne connaît pas non plus de temple public,
ou en tout cas la fonction cultuelle des
édifices est pour l’instant passée inaperçue.
Étonnant car ces deux types de bâtiments,
temple et palais, sont d’habitude les plus
massifs et les mieux conservés. Pas de tombes
princières non plus à se mettre sous la dent.
L’absence de conflits visibles pose aussi
question. Les épais remparts de certaines villes,
par exemple 18 mètres d’épaisseur et 9 mètres de
haut à Dholavira (icono), ne semblent pas avoir
subi d’autre assaut que celui des inondations.
Ces murs, souvent interprétés comme défensifs
sur la base de ce qu’on connaît dans les autres
régions du monde, étaient peut-être de simples
digues dans bien des cas. On ne connaît d’ailleurs
pas d’armes forgées, que des pointes de flèches,
aussi bien utilisées pour la chasse.
Pas de pouvoir, pas de religion,
pas de guerre ? La vallée de l’Indus commence
à ressembler à une véritable utopie. Mais
c’est sans doute trop beau pour être vrai.
L’abondance de salles de bain dans les maisons
fait tout de même penser à des usages rituels de
l'eau, et le Grand bassin de Mohenjo-Daro situé
sur un point haut de la ville pourrait lui
aussi avoir eu une fonction religieuse. Les
foyers dans les maisons pourraient aussi avoir
joué un rôle pour des rituels domestiques et les
quelques sculptures de pierre de Mohenjo-Daro bien
qu’incomplètes étaient peut-être des portraits de
souverains. La mieux conservée est généralement
interprétée comme un “prêtre-roi”, sans qu’on
ait d’autres indices à ce sujet. Beaucoup de
statuettes grossières en terre cuite représentant
des femmes ont par ailleurs été interprétées
comme des déesses-mères, mais on a déjà expliqué
sur cette chaîne la faiblesse de cette théorie.
Quelques figures énigmatiques sur des décors
de poteries ou de sceaux gravés pourraient
correspondre à des divinités ou des figures
mythologiques, mais en l’absence de textes, il
est impossible de les identifier. On a aussi
souvent voulu tracer des correspondances
avec les religions indiennes postérieures,
en y voyant des positions évoquant le yoga par
exemple, mais là encore, il n’y a rien de certain.
Face à cette absence apparente d’un Etat,
certains archéologues avancent l’idée que
la civilisation d’Harappa n’était pas centralisée
mais plutôt une sorte de fédération de marchands.
L’uniformité de la culture matérielle,
ne serait donc pas la conséquence d’une
unification politique mais plutôt de réseaux
de distribution interne très développés.
C’est le cas par exemple pour le silex gris du
gisement de Rohri, diffusé dans toute la vallée.
Les échanges d’Harappa avec l’extérieur sont par
ailleurs bien attestés. On a retrouvé les produits
fabriqués dans la vallée de l’Indus dans tout
le Moyen-Orient. Les perles d’agate, cornaline,
jaspe, onyx ou en coquillages, typiques
d’Harappa, ont été largement identifiées
en Mésopotamie ou dans la péninsule
arabique. En échange des exportations,
Harappa devait recevoir des produits périssables,
sans doute de la laine que les Mésopotamiens
produisaient en quantité industrielle.
L’Indus était donc au cœur d’un commerce
international mais paradoxalement pas du
tout tourné vers l’Inde, uniquement vers
l’ouest. Les routes terrestres vers l’ouest
et le nord traversaient le plateau iranien,
où des sites sont connus aux carrefours
stratégiques. Cela permettait de contrôler la
production de certains matériaux, comme le bois
des montagnes himalayennes ou les ressources du
sous-sol, métaux et pierres semi-précieuses
comme la turquoise et le lapis-lazuli.
L’un des éléments les plus probants de cette
organisation commerciale à grande échelle sont
les sceaux inscrits. De forme carrée, portant un
dessin d’animal et quelques caractères d’écriture,
ils sont les artefacts les plus iconiques
de la civilisation harappéenne. Ils sont
faits la plupart du temps en stéatite et
durcis au feu. Percés sur la face opposée,
ils étaient faits pour être portés en pendentif
ou à la ceinture. Leur fonction semble avoir
été d’identifier les personnes à l’origine
d’une transaction commerciale, et à marquer
sur un support comme l’argile ou la cire, la
propriété des marchandises. Malheureusement
très peu de ces supports nous sont parvenus
(icono, trois fragments d’argile imprimée).
Le fait que les sceaux ne soient presque présents
que dans les villes d’Harappa et Mohenjo-Daro,
fait penser que ces deux villes jouaient un rôle
privilégié dans une organisation administrative.
Mais c’est aussi peut-être un biais de
conservation car ailleurs des sceaux en argile
ont été accidentellement préservés par un feu.
La figure animale la plus courante sur les sceaux
est appelée la « licorne », une représentation
stylisée d’un quadrupède avec une seule corne,
mélangeant les caractères de bovins et d’antilope
(icono). Pour certains, la licorne aurait donc été
le clan dominant de la vallée de l’Indus.
Pour d’autres, les animaux sur les sceaux
symboliseraient des métiers ou des fonctions
sociales, et la licorne pourrait être ainsi le
symbole de l’Etat. Mais la clé est sans doute
dans les inscriptions qui leurs sont associées.
Les nombreuses tentatives de déchiffrement
de l’écriture harappéenne sont pour l’instant
infructueuses, pour de nombreuses raisons :
absence d’inscription bilingue, signes abstraits,
inscriptions très courtes, méconnaissance
de la langue qu’elle servait à transcrire
et absence d’écriture postérieure dérivée.
A tel point que certains spécialistes comme
Steve Farmer doutent même qu’il s’agisse
d’une écriture, mais penchent plutôt pour
un système de symboles non-linguistiques.
Puisqu’on ne connaît pas de textes longs,
de représentations de scribes, d’évolution
vers une écriture plus cursive, bref,
tout ce qu’on connaît ailleurs,
il s’agit peut-être d’autre chose.
Plusieurs chercheurs ont affirmé avoir déchiffré
l’écriture harappéenne au XXe siècle, mais leurs
hypothèses se sont toujours avérées arbitraires et
impossibles à généraliser. On attend de nouvelles
trouvailles qui permettront de progresser. On
sait juste que le texte devait se lire de droite à
gauche car quand les caractères ne remplissent pas
toute une ligne, ils commencent toujours à droite.
La disparition des grandes villes au début du
deuxième millénaire avant notre ère est elle aussi
énigmatique. Les fouilles anciennes ont révélé un
urbanisme plus sommaire dans les phases tardives,
voire des squatteurs installés dans les ruines,
ainsi que des nouveaux motifs de poterie,
qui pourraient indiquer l’arrivée de nouvelles
populations, mais cela n’est pas le cas partout.
Pour expliquer cet effondrement, une invasion de
populations aryennes, de langue indo-européenne,
a très souvent été évoquée. Les récits sanskrits
du Veda gardent en effet la mémoire de ces grandes
migrations aryennes vers le cœur de l’Inde au
XVe siècle avant notre ère. Mais les nombreuses
datations sont aujourd’hui assez claires,
la fin d’Harappa, vers 1750 avant J.-C., les
précède de plusieurs siècles. Et puis malgré les
fantasmes de certains fouilleurs, aucune trace de
conflit n’a été mise en évidence dans les villes.
Attention donc à ne pas surinterpréter le rôle des
mystérieux Indo-européens, comme c’est souvent le
cas. Il faut partir des vestiges archéologiques et
ne pas chercher à les plier à des reconstructions
linguistiques ou des récits mythiques. Dans l’état
actuel de nos connaissances, on peut penser
que les Indo-européens n’auraient fait en somme
que combler le vide laissé par Harappa, et les
causes du déclin doivent être cherchées ailleurs.
Les autres hypothèses pour la fin de
la civilisation de l’Indus qui ont été
avancées sont l’épuisement des sols, mais
il y a un tel apport d’alluvions fertiles
du fleuve que cela paraît difficile. En
revanche les maladies comme le paludisme,
favorisé par l’inondation de champs toujours plus
étendus, a dû être un fléau assez impitoyable.
Les études de paléopathologie qui ont été menées
sur les squelettes de Mohenjo-Daro montrent que
la malaria était particulièrement répandue,
sans doute associée au choléra. L’obsession
des harappéens pour l’hygiène et les salles de
bain serait peut-être à comprendre en ce sens.
Comme on l’a dit en début de vidéo, les cours
d’eau ont aussi changé de lit régulièrement,
et les épisodes de sécheresses et inondations
auraient pu fragiliser les villes. La rivière
Saraswati a par exemple entièrement
disparu au début du deuxième millénaire,
alors qu’elle abritait une très forte densité de
sites d’habitat, notamment la grande agglomération
de Ganweriwala. Le changement de lit de la rivière
a dû être une catastrophe fatale, mais sans doute
pas à l’échelle de toute la civilisation.
Il y a une autre possibilité, qu’on avait
déjà évoquée dans une vidéo précédente d’ailleurs
: la dépendance économique. La fin de l’Indus est
peut-être à mettre en lien avec le déclin
de nombreuses villes de Mésopotamie du sud
au même moment, à cause d’une salinisation des
sols qui fait fortement baisser les rendements
agricoles. Le pouvoir politique se déplace vers
le nord de la Mésopotamie au deuxième millénaire,
ce qui a sans doute distendu les liens avec
l’Indus. La perte de ce partenaire commercial
pourrait avoir fragilisé l’économie harappéenne.
L’effondrement, graduel et pas soudain comme on
l’a longtemps pensé, s’étale en réalité entre 2000
et 1750 BC, époque à laquelle les sites orientaux,
du Gujarat et du Gange notamment voient leur
population augmenter. Plus qu’un effondrement,
c’est sans doute un abandon du cœur du
territoire avec un déplacement vers les marges
qu’on voit s’opérer dans la vallée de l’Indus.
Origine, système politique, religion, écriture,
langue, peuplement, disparition, tout ou
presque reste donc largement mystérieux
concernant Harappa, et on espère que les
programmes archéologiques en cours vont nous
apporter d’incroyables nouvelles hypothèses.
Merci à tous, bien sûr il y a plein de nuances
à apporter à cette présentation rapide alors
n’hésitez pas à aller trouver des informations
complémentaires. Je mets comme d’habitude
les sources qui ont servi à préparer la vidéo
en barre d’info...Je remercie Lucas Pacotte à
l’écriture et la documentation. Chers abonnés
merci encore une fois de votre soutien : vos
partages, likes, commentaires et dons aident
véritablement la chaîne ! Depuis quelques mois
il y a une transformation qui se passe et qui
permet à la chaîne d’être reconnue. Des projets
incroyables arrivent et vous n’y êtes pas pour
rien, merci ! Avant le prochain épisode, petite
surprise : je suis sur France Culture du 22 au
26 dans l’Emission Sans Oser le demander,
je vous ai préparé des petites chroniques
archéologiques et j’espère que ça vous plaira.
Je vous embrasse et je vous dis à très vite !